[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 4th of
november i'm fraser nelson coming up in
the next hour we look at joe biden's
political crisis he's back from the
climate change summit in glasgow but
he's found his party being defeated in
the previously safe state of virginia so
what went right for the republicans and
have they found the recipe for winning
the next presidential election i talked
to freddie gray and jacob halbron we
then go to westminster where there's yet
another tory debacle in a scandal over
lobbying and the government's botched
attempts to reform the system under
which mps themselves are governed i
speak to james forsyth and katie balls
about how the government managed to get
this so badly wrong
then we'll look at the cop summit a
former chancellor and former editor of
the spectator nigel lawson writes on
this week's issue that it's all a little
bit of a fraud but is it we talked to
gavin schmitz from nasa and to benny
pfizer from the global warming policy
foundation and finally clara is it the
new digital loan shark or the consumer
spending tool of the future i talked to
cella creasy the labour mp for
wolfenstein and scourge of the payday
lenders about whether she has found her
new enemy but before we get going to
make sure you never miss an episode of
this show do click on subscribe in the
button just below me on the screen if
you click the bell it will make sure
that you're alerted every time a new
episode of the show comes on and if you
want to try the magazine itself we're
offering a pretty good deal for just 12
pounds you get a 20 pound amazon voucher
and three months free of the magazine
and full online access and no the maths
don't make sense to me either but it's
their spectator dot co dot uk forward
slash tv offer for our trial
subscription
now on to our first item what's the
state of play in america when joe biden
got back he found his party had lost the
big race in virginia a state which he
personally won by 10 percentage points
just a year ago
so freddie gray in his cover piece
portrays joe biden as a fallen superman
lying in the beach is that fair we
talked to jacob harbour he joins me now
from a vietnamese cafe in washington dc
and freddie joins me from well upstairs
in the office in london freddie are you
being a bit mean to
joe biden all presidents will lose
midterm election how bad is this really
well i'm well aware that
presidents can turn things around
i suppose the point of my piece is that
the outlook is very grim for biden on
all fronts
it wasn't just
virginia last night i mean he the
democratic party are failing all over
the country and more broadly his job
approval rating is collapsing
uh americans who think the country is on
the wrong track
are increasing it's about 71 percent now
there's a general sense that the biden
presidency is a disaster
and it's uh quite serious for biden
because for a long time he just surfed
off the fact that he wasn't donald trump
and that he wasn't causing the sort of
cultural aggravation that everybody
thought that trump caused
uh the trouble is now he seems to be
leading over a country doesn't know what
he's what it's doing
and that's a big problem for biden jacob
you supported joe biden as did most
spectator columnists who had a vote in
the election are you feeling a bit
disappointed now it seems as if your
your man is beginning to lose the
electoral coalition after just a few
months
i think that uh unfortunately i can't
disagree with freddie as much as i
normally would with my usual
vigor
come on you can try you can try i was
expecting that freddy would be gloating
this morning he's being fairly
restrained but there is much to gloat
over
and i think the principal difficulties
that biden is experiencing
are not are that he's not holy master of
his own fate
the the russians in congress
between the democrats have turned into a
psycho drama
over these infrastructure and social
spending bills
so biden really has very little
to show the electorate and that was
that's certainly hamstrung terry
mcauliffe in the virginia elections
this has been compounded
by
the
almost parasitic infestation of woke
ideology
into american
schools and colleges
which
the democrats kept announcing during the
virginia election that there was no such
thing as critical race theory
that republicans were making this up and
that it isn't actually taught in the
schools
now this is i think somewhat
disingenuous while it's true that this
abstruse doctrine of critical race
theory
may not specifically be taught in the
school
it has become a a code word
or a broader term
for both woke
and cancel culture which have become
fairly pervasive in america
and in this regard
i think that biden may need to have a
sister soldier moment where he publicly
divorces and emancipates himself from
these ideologies
all right but fairly this was supposed
to be the great advantage of joe biden
wasn't he basically he was too old to
understand what we're commenced doesn't
understand what navy's initials meant
but the strange thing is that in
virginia and critical race theory was
not taught in any schools it absorbed a
lot of the political conversation
so at the summer expense do you think
the republicans are riding on a kind of
false narrative here they got away with
it this time talking about critical race
theories if it was a real thing in
virginia schools but it wasn't and maybe
verlock might not hold for that much
longer
i think there's an element to
to into which that glenn young in the
successful virginia uh now governor
of virginia uh exploited the fact that
he could disassociate himself from trump
or the red raw elements of trumpism but
he could still appeal to the culture war
fight over critical race theory and he
won on that basis i think a lot of party
republicans are perhaps getting a little
bit excite over excited about this and
they're saying we have a we have a way
out of rep out of trumpism in which we
can sort of take the good bits the
successful bits of trumpism electorally
and we can get rid of the nasty stuff
that puts off most voters i think
there's a little bit of over-enthusiasm
there this is just one
one result
but it definitely spells trouble for the
democrats because they are lumbered with
biden who personally invested himself in
this virginia race
and who ended up
losing and the fact that his
intervention didn't just not help it
seemed to actually make the situation
worse because his popularity is so bad
so going into the midterms next year
the democrats look to be in serious
serious trouble
and jacob when you look at who voted in
virginia there's a very interesting
passion a pattern that we hadn't really
seen since trump's first election in
2016. that is that the democrat vote
turned up as strongly as they thought
but there were the republican votes
turned up in even greater numbers and
it's where it turned up that matters
we're talking about the places outside
the cities a far stronger rural vote in
other words it seems that the people who
turned up for trump in 2016 who didn't
then show up in subsequent midterms are
for some reason coming back so the trump
coalition is coming together at the same
time that the democrat coalition is
falling apart because we're hearing lots
of of civil war in democrats if you look
at buffalo and new york you've got there
and a competition between two democrats
one a self-styled
socialist democrat the first socialist
and leader there for like 50 years who
was taking on a centrist democrat there
for one so we're seeing civil war in the
left but cohesion on the right is that a
fair analysis
i think actually it is
not only was yunkan able to mobilize the
the republican trump supporters but he
was also able to cut in deeply
into the uh
independent voters by appealing on
issues of education
and taxes
so i put more credence into the younkin
victory than freddie appears to i think
younkin does offer the republican party
a winning formula for the midterm
elections
and indeed
i suspect
that he will be a potent candidate for
the presidency in 2024.
youngkin is not a professional
politician
he is someone who is a highly successful
businessman at the carlisle group
and he
has toppled the last vestige of the
clinton empire i mean terry mcauliffe
was a constituent element
of bill clinton's runs for the
presidency he's a fantastic fundraiser
but he also has a reputation as a
sleazebag to put it bluntly
uh this is a tremendous
victory for the republicans today there
also
appeared to be on the verge of winning
the governorship in new jersey which no
one had even expected that to me is more
telling than the virginia election
the fact is
it's not the the democrats are whining
that the problem is messaging it's not
messaging it's the message that they're
delivering the message is not finding a
receptive audience right now
and freddie junkin's message certainly
did and i wonder what you think of
jacob's point that he could be a
presidential candidate because here's
somebody who's told his language was
quite restrained not at all nutty like
donald trump yet was still unafraid to
talk about critical race theory the
issues obviously matter quite a lot to
the people who voted for him so is he
proving that voters are being turned
away from the sort of more radical
aspects of democrats and are willing to
vote for a republican as long as he
doesn't sound like a nut
i think it's certainly true that if you
can be branded as an extremist by the
democrats when you're clearly not
you're going to win votes because what
junkie was doing was saying there's this
critical racist issue in critical race
theory issue in schools
and it's something that voters don't
like
and the democratic reaction to that was
you're a trumpist nazi effectively and
you're a racist and anyone who agrees
with you as a racist
and a lot of parents who are worried
about this said
no and these are not trumpist parents
they are sort of independent parents he
said no we don't like critical race
theory in schools we're going to side
with yonkin and that's what got him his
swing
i i my point about whether young king
can work is the future of hook in canada
is a it's way too early
uh but b
why why do we think that the republicans
have suddenly found a formula because of
one
race the point is they have fundamental
differences between the trumpist base
that think the election was stolen and
it was interesting last night when the
results were coming in a lot of the
trump people online were saying they're
about to steal it they're about to rig
it it's all about to go wrong because
the democrats are in charge
it that doesn't turn that doesn't turn
true so do we do we really invest faith
in this idea
that the republicans are going to find
some sort of happy middle ground between
culture wars fighting but not trumpism
so sort of amiable media friendly
culture wars fighting i don't think
that's a recipe for long-term success
but i'm very willing to accept i could
be wrong
freddie and jacob thanks very much well
another um biden voter in our ranks is
lionel shriver who in her colon says
that she is worried that things are
heading in a direction that might seem
like donald trump and kamala harris
coming towards us for a
jewel in the next presidential election
lionel thanks for joining us on
spectator tv
what do you think is going wrong for the
democrats
oh god where do i start
um there are two big stories that are
going wrong with the democrats one of
them of course is over which is the
shambolic withdrawal from afghanistan it
was a very bad look
even for
a population which in majority supported
uh the u.s getting out
it was
badly done
seemed unamerican
disorganized made us look bad
internationally everything that biden
promised that he was going to fix
and of course the other big story is
immigration
ever since biden took office the border
has been a free-for-all and
you know there are all these pictures
coming through on the news of
huge crowds of people pouring over the
border
border patrol agents actually opening
gates to let them through
it's like what's going on here it looks
it looks as if we have a de facto open
border policy and that is not broadly
popular it's popular among a very narrow
band of progressives on the extreme left
of the democratic party but for the most
part americans
support controlled immigration they can
they support immigration but they want
it to be legal
um and they want us to have some kind of
you know command over who is is allowed
in and not
so uh
the column i wrote uh this
this week is about a story which is
just perfectly designed to backfire
um
listeners may
remember that trump had a very unpopular
policy of
dividing families
of illegal immigrants at the border and
separating parents from their children
i was surprised to
look up that it lasted less than a
couple of months but
you would never have known it um because
ever since the democrats have run with
that story
and
given lots of play to the
the terrible plight of
of children who felt abandoned and
um had nobody to take care of them
there were instances
in which nobody kept track of
where the children were and where the
parents were so it became almost
impossible to reunite them
the pictures were horrific and
uh democrats have made a lot of hay out
of you know so-called children in cages
right so the thing with lineup the
donald trump spoke about nothing more uh
i was speaking about china the mexican
border two of his big themes as
president he was going to build a wall
we all remember that um but americans
decided that that sort of style of
politics was just to be grating they
turned away from it
joe biden was always going to he always
talked about it
one of his policies is offering an
amnesty for example to illegal migrants
and increasing the immigration cap
although he's moved back from what he
was proposing earlier on but didn't
americans vote
for a more liberal approach the border
policy and a more humane approach when
it came to addressing the
the issue of people of parents separated
from their children under the donald
trump formula i mean that was i'm sure
you'll accept that was a bad policy that
does deserve to be redressed
oh it was bad that certainly family
separation was a terrible policy
and it it did deserve to be addressed
and it was withdrawn by trump himself i
mean he
it backfired fantastically in the press
and uh as it should have done
so yes but i think americans voted for
biden expecting a a moderate policy and
you know it's it's
or at least a policy
actually uh
biden has not successfully passed any
legislation that would address the large
numbers of illegal immigrants it already
in the country but he also has not got
control of the border and to the
contrary
has sent out
implicit messages to anyone who wants to
come in
that this is the time to do it you know
biden is going to welcome you
these are mixed messages but the real
messages that matter are what happens to
you if you cross the border illegally
are you beginning to regret voting for
joe biden then no i mean what was the
alternative the alternative was to vote
for donald trump and i have never
supported him
and found his presidency very painful
even though there are a few of of
trump's policies
that
you know on an ideological or or
practical level i supported uh
he gave them a bad name you know
supporting controlled immigration
got a bad reputation because
during the trump years and it meant oh
you want to build a wall and and and of
course it it
it meant that you you were a racist and
he tarnished a lot of positions that are
that would have been defensible
uh if he hadn't been backing them
right but despite that bad reputation
despite all of that tarnishing you
finish your columns saying i'm looking
in wide-eyed horror as kamala and the
donald in 2024 as if standing
mid-motorway with two headlights of an
htv battling towards me and not being
able to move in other words you now
envisage him coming back despite all of
the rancor and all of the things which
you yourself ended up voting against
well
i can't stand kamal harris
um oh and by the way i have i have tons
of company on that point she is
wildly unpopular popular in the united
states and i was amused to discover in a
poll in the times recently the london
times
uh that she's just as unpopular over
here i mean it's rather astonishing that
anybody has
in the uk has an opinion about her one
way or another but she's so disagreeable
and also incompetent um that that she
puts people off from 3 000 miles away
um
so i desperately do not want to vote for
kamal harris for president
but i also don't want to vote for donald
trump i mean that's what i mean it
leaves me in a state of terrified
paralysis and i'm not one of those
people who believes that oh you can
refuse to vote and not get your hands
dirty because that's a way of making
your feelings felt so i don't like
either of these candidates if they
really are
the candidates in 2024
then
then i will have to vote for one of them
and
i would never have thought i would say
this but i would be a little torn
um
because i think kamal harris would be a
catastrophic president
and uh i'm just i'm really hoping
something happens
now just to make this not happen
that's not the choice that the american
people are are presented with
uh in the next right but
you're sounding a bit downbeat here i
mean in britain we have to choose uh as
prime minister has got to be one of the
650 old people elected to parliament in
america anybody can be president you can
choose between 333 million um ingenious
souls here so surely this this country
of yours can produce something a little
more inspiring than kamila harris or
donald trump they mean yeah you would
think
and you know that this hits me in
virtually every election
this is the best we can do um
it is freakish in itself that biden of
all the people in the world ended up
president
of much less trump
but
these things are arranged
way ahead of time
um and it it is not
unusual for
not just someone like me who's merely on
the sidelines despairing
but
you know
people who are central to the running of
both parties to already be considering
uh
whom we're going to run in 24 and you
know how that's going to work out
and i
i think that there may be some
possibility that ron desantis
could
give trump some competition
he's the governor of florida and has
done a very good job of holding out
against
draconian measures during covid uh
he's
florida has some of the best coveted
stats in the union right now
um
but you know he would have to be start
being positioned
hugely in advance i will say that there
is one
optimistic note i could sound here
um
i mean i for one
want
desperately for republicans to separate
themselves from trump there's no reason
that
the positions that he
represents necessarily have to be
pursued by that man
um
so the
the gubernatorial contest in virginia
that whose results just came in
uh i i find promising and that's not
just
it's not just the absolute result of the
republican
uh uh glenn younkin
winning
over against a democratic
uh terry mcauliffe
candidate that uh
who was expected to win to begin with
but it's it's how youngkin won
and
younkin did not
associate himself with trump
he meant went to considerable lengths to
keep
up from being associated too closely
with trump while his opponent mcauliffe
went to equal lengths to associate
his republican opponent with trump it
didn't work and i thought it was very
promising that trump stayed out of that
that election and that
uh younkin prevailed
uh
in spite of the fact that he put
distance between
himself and trump in other words the
this business of not necessarily trying
to ride trump's coattails and and suck
up to trump and and go for specifically
for the
trump voter
uh
it worked
lana shriver thanks very much indeed now
back to home where westminster is a
pretty strange week we started not
knowing if britain was going to enter
some kind of conflict with france over
fishing bows and we've ended with a
conflict with the conservative party and
the parliamentary authorities over how
mps should be governed i'm joined by
katie balls and james forsyth so james
on the face of it this looks pretty
strange doesn't it so standards
committee finds against owen patterson
the tory mp and the tories respond by
saying this isn't fair let's get rid of
the committee and set up one that we
like to look off a little bit more
yeah and then even more strange
the government is then forced uh by a
backlash from the public and from the
opposition parties and from its own mps
in into uh abandoning its effort to
change the rules so uh on uh wednesday
afternoon tory mps were whipped to vote
for uh a new system that was going to
start looking at reforms for a complaint
system
and the patterson suspension was was put
into a balance uh then huge backlash um
very very bad front pages on thursday
morning for the government uh and the
government then jake reese morgan comes
to a house uh business uh questions this
morning and says no we don't want to
proceed on the the previous base will
proceed on a cross-party basis there
will be a vote on the owen patterson
suspension and a tory pbs who lost her
job for abstaining rather than voting
with the government whip on paterson has
now been reinstated to a job it is a
debacler of parliamentary management it
is a massive political mistake that put
the government on the wrong side of
public opinion
on a very evocative issue you know
british politics has still not um
entirely recovered from the mps expenses
scandal
and i i think there are a lot of
very irate or emps this morning who
don't understand why they were uh you
know marched into this minefield and
then marched out of it again and james
just remind us how much was owen
patterson being paid by the lobbyists
uh i think it was something around 100
000 pounds a year right um katie isn't
this james mentioned the expenses
scandal i mean
you can said at the time look i claimed
a duck house and expenses but that was
within the rules i claimed to moat and
expenses technically i didn't break the
rules
aren't the tories making exactly the
same mistake here for saying what owen
patterson did wasn't in the rules by the
way that's debatable but fundamentally
if you're taking a hundred grand a year
from a lobbyist way more than your mp
salary that's going to strike the public
as wrong so what is it why couldn't the
tories see that so i think there's two
issues going on here one is the owen
patterson case specifically the second
is uh standards commissioner and how the
tory party generally be the standards
commissioner i think on the owen peston
case as we touched on and two companies
a report by the standards commissioner
that really found that it was not just a
minor breach of lobbying rules but a
major one um in terms of contacting
ministers and other and ultimately owen
paterson's defenders say well actually
he did this in good faith it was for
welfare cause and the investigation was
flawed because uh witnesses were never
called that would have helped in his
defense you add to the fact that owen
patterson says that his wife um his
wife's suicide was connected to this
investigation and there are some who uh
troubled by the findings of the report
but think there should be um
ultimately a special uh measures put in
to take into account the tragedy that he
has suffered
now
i think the the issue is when you come
to that breach most people who read the
report say well this is against the
rules even if it is well intentioned now
i think where this has stopped being
okay is just about owen patterson but a
much wider issue that tory mps really
fear could hurt them and add to this
torres lee's narrative is how
number 10 and the government were quite
happy yesterday to use their own
patterson case as a vehicle to
ultimately move how you judge standards
and i think the idea of mps uh
regulating themselves mp an mp committee
deciding uh what uh rules and standards
mps should live by um is clearly
troubling and does have um echoes to the
expense of scandal i think there are
people who've looked at this and thought
have we not learned anything this is
clearly gonna land badly and we've seen
in the past 24 hours it has landed very
badly with the public but it means that
lots of mps are now just asking why
number 10 thought for a second they
would be able to get away with this
james that's a good question you don't
need to be mystic meg to imagine that
this sort of thing will go down badly
with the public now we also hear that
boris made the decision after well he
was used at glasgow for the g26 summit
now perhaps he'd had his fill of all of
his environmentalism because we then
read it he and then got a private jet
flew down to london had dinner with our
colleague charles murr by the way i can
completely understand why you would want
to do that get away from the madness of
cop and come and talk sense of charles
murr but it seems that between that
dinner and the next day a decision was
made and people aren't quite clear how
that decision was made i've spoken to a
few touring pieces who are baffled as to
the thought process behind this and they
see this as yet another sign of number
10 making decisions
in a way
which shows a striking inability to
think about the political consequences
perhaps because there's a chief of staff
there dan rosenfeld who isn't a
politician who doesn't really know much
about politics but it seems nobody there
is really saying prime minister by all
means do this if you want but the
political backlash will be absolutely
huge and maybe you want to think twice
before you're forced into a u-turn
yeah i think this is a decision that was
tightly held you speak to uh some people
who you thought might have been
consulted on it
and they weren't and there is obviously
a blame game playing out at the moment a
lot of people are are criticizing the
chief whip um i'm told that there were
back bench delegations to him on tuesday
and wednesday saying how do you think
this is going to play out this is this
is going to be a disaster um not not
just for the tory party but for everyone
concerned and in the way that it has
been you know in that you know aaron
patterson is undoubtedly in a worse
situation today than he would have been
if a commons had simply voted on his
suspension on on wednesday
and so i think there is i think this
will lead to lots of questions about how
on earth is happening because
this was a this was an obvious political
problem sometimes in politics there is a
backlash to something and and it is
unexpected that it is not on anyone's
list of issues i think you know
i think sewage for example which you saw
recently is an issue that was something
which people didn't quite anticipate how
controversial that was going to be
this was obviously going to cause a
stink because as you put it quite simply
a tory mp is found guilty by uh the
standards committee and then tory mps
seek to essentially reverse the verdict
that was always going to cause a row and
i think there will be that tory mps are
are angry because they think this is
such a self-inflicted um self-inflicted
injury and they can't see why they were
trying what what anyone was trying to
achieve because
the other point about the report is but
uh the report
acknowledges that um boston 40 was doing
the right thing when he made his various
interventions
but i think the problem is is the sheer
level of communication you know it's not
like there was a one-off message to
alert people to the problem that have
been discovered
it's the continuing messages it's the
fact that the meetings took place on the
parliamentary estate when uh when
they're not meant to and i think i think
it would have been much better to have
accepted the commission's verdict and
then said look there are problems about
the lack of an appeals process there are
problems about the fact that you know
this process will be better handled by
someone with more legal experience to
ensure that you know that there that
that it that it but it but it it
comports more to how a court would
behave um but these were all changes
that would have been better done after
the judgment had been handed down in
this case rather than trying to pause or
reverse the judgment in this case
and katie is there a wider moral to this
story i mean i mean i personally found
it surprising that mps were allowed
to take um nine thousand pounds a month
from lobbyists more than they're paid to
be mps you'd think they would say look
um if owen patton did it in good faith
he believed in the causes he was
representing fine but tell them to give
the money to the party not to him
personally because there'll be a
conflict of interest that would be
rather difficult to explain away to your
your average voters so do you think
there might be a wider question to be
had here about whether mp should be
allowed to be paid to lobby for external
companies while doing their
parliamentary duties yeah i think there
could be and i think if you look at some
of the defenses of owen patterson this
idea um that actually he was acting as a
whistleblower and that's one thing but i
think then you look at the salary and
the money attached and you start to
think well this doesn't feel as a
conventional as you might imagine the
whistleblower role i think that one of
the mistakes downing street has made in
terms of how they've handled this is
actually
by uh looking as though it's almost a
club looking after its own i think you
increase the chance of people starting
to say well should you really be having
a second job and going back to this
debate about um you know
muddying interests and whether
westminster can be trusted to um you
know even operate on their own rules
that then bring in their new rules and i
do think uh
the way the story is going to go i think
there's going to be more scrutiny more
coverage of potentially uh you know
conflicts of interest within um
westminster within parliament and i
don't think that's going to be
comfortable for some mps that actually
as james touches on i think there was a
way to avoid this um but it's now taking
on a life of its own that's not going to
be comfortable for the government or
many tory mps
katie and james thanks very much now a
reminder that you can get katie and
james's take on politics every day on
coffeehouse shots our free podcast you
can find it by typing in coffeehouse
shots on your podcast search engine
now on to the cop 26 climates change
summit in glasgow it's now halfway
through but are we really getting a
debate
this week's issue has got an article by
nigel lawson a former chancellor and of
course this magazine's former editor
where he says that a lot of his
discussion is on a false premise he's
not convinced that there is a great um
tragedy about to unfold and he was
saying the solutions being proposed will
make things worse not better well we
also have a piece from gavin schmitz
who's a climate change scientist at nasa
he argues that things are every bit as
bad as people say he joins me now as
does benny pfizer from the global
warming policy foundation which nigel
lawson helped to set up now gavin
schmitz let's start with you first isn't
it simply the case that the renewable
energy revolution we're hoping for isn't
going to come along in time to hit the
next zero target and us as such the
conversation we're having isn't quite in
tune with reality unless we're talking
about nuclear power which from what i
gather is banned from even exhibiting at
the cop26 summit then we're really not
going to get to the whole picture that
would allow britain to transition
properly away from fossil fuels well
let's take a little bit of a step back
why are we doing all of this right we
have seen over a degree change in global
temperatures we're seeing that having
impacts directly in heat waves and
intense rainfall and in storms and in
sea level rise and in coastal flooding
and in intense precipitation we are
seeing the impacts right now of the
climate changes we've already had we
know what's causing them we know that
it's being driven mainly by our
emissions of greenhouse gases
particularly carbon dioxide and we can
predict what's going to happen into the
future now those damages are going to
occur they're already occurring and if
we don't stop the emissions
those damages will increase and so now
we have a situation where we know that
certain activities uh that we indulge in
as a society are having harm and the
moral thing to do is to see if we can
mitigate that harm right and so the
discussions at glasgow the discussions
that are going on uh elsewhere around
the world uh related to this are all
about how fast can we stop doing that
harm
it's not that complicated now
how that happens how fast that happens
those are going to be very difficult
decisions because it depends on the
technology which for renewables has been
getting cheaper and cheaper and cheaper
it depends on how we um organize our
societies what what rules we mandate
what uh what subsidies we give what what
taxes we impose all of those things are
going to affect uh how much emissions go
on into the future but the key thing
that comes from the science
is the realization that all of the
future warming and the future impacts
are actually related to our future
emissions and so any reduction in
emissions that we have going forward
is going to reduce damages into the
future and so every little bit counts
and so whether we can uh
uh you know have an argument well you
know is this conceivable by 2050 or by
2060 or by 2070 none of those real
things really matter too much as long as
we're on the trajectory that is reducing
those emissions and that's the only way
that we're going to reduce those harms
but the question to cop 26 is whether um
countries can sign up to a net zero
pledge by 2050. now britain is one of
them well well that's not that's not
quite right so so cop 26 is the
opportunity after five years after the
paris accord uh for countries to
upgrade their independently determined
uh contributions to those reductions
and different countries are
independently coming up with ideas about
what they think that they can do right
nobody is imposing that upon them they
are independently saying we think that
we can do this now i don't wanna i'm not
gonna say that the uk can't do what it's
saying or that china can't do what it's
saying uh i have to trust that they know
what they're talking about because i
can't go in and check everything for
them
right but
what's going on is that they're becoming
more ambitious and uh by setting goals
like net zero carbon dioxide by 2050 uh
their singling um and putting into place
by law in the uk are mechanisms and ways
to get there
so bendy fires the renewables are
becoming cheaper all the time therefore
i put you but it's quite credible that
things will develop in the way the
british government says they will
yeah i was a bit cynical um
let's face it what we've heard for the
last 10 minutes is the kind of
mantra we've heard for the last 30 years
what's the problem with it what's gavin
schmitz said which is incorrect
well
nothing
that western governments have done
in throwing
trillions at renewables have
halted the rise of co2 co2 is rising
steadily
and if renewables were as cheap as gavin
claims
most governments would adopt them the
reason why
we have the problem at cop 26 is that
china india and the rest of the
developing world can realize just how
bad the situation is in britain and in
europe with energy prices going through
the roof and renewables causing all
sorts of unintended consequences
like yesterday where consumers had to
pay 50 million to keep the lights on so
as i said if renewables are so cheap as
we've been told over and over again
there wouldn't be a problem the problem
is
governments don't take this seriously
otherwise we wouldn't have the problem
we have right
realistically
co2 emissions will continue to rise for
the next 10 years they're not going to
go down
and governments around the world are not
adopting
radical decarbonization policies and
that's the real that's the reality
but let's look at the reality in britain
then britain is a country where we
decarbonize faster than any other g20
country over the last 10 years no matter
how much you measure it our co2
emissions are now back down to levels
not seen since the victorian days
renewables the strike price of wind
power is coming down all the time in a
way far lower than people thought it
would be 10 years ago and sure china
isn't following suit the world isn't
following suit but if you look the model
that britain has adopted isn't that a
model where renewables take an ever
greater part of the strain and that's a
model that china or india could one day
adopt when they get rich enough and all
of a sudden we can see a path for the
world to hit net zero and for global
warming temperatures to be restricted to
1.5
yeah it's it's it's a great story
unfortunately no one around the world is
actually buying into it otherwise they
would adopt the british model what they
are seeing is uh britain struggling at
europe struggling with an extreme energy
crisis energy prices going through the
roof and we're facing uh real problems
with stabilizing the national grid as i
said yesterday 50 million just to keep
the lights on so um
as i said if this if britain were such a
trailblazer many countries would adopt
similar policies the reason that most
developing and emerging nations don't
and are refusing to adopt these policies
is they can see that they're not working
they're not working at all
most of our
manufacturing
high energy industries have already
moved abroad because you can't afford to
invest in britain if you use a lot of
energy it's far too expensive in europe
basically those industries have to be
subsidized left right and center so
the reality is there is a deep divide
international divide there's no way out
and
most of the developing world for the
next 10 20 30 years will use
cheap
abundant available fossil fuels right
that's the and all energy agencies are
actually predicting that by 2050 still
half of the global energy mix will be
based on fossil fuels now gavin schmidt
that's a a fair point isn't this because
we all know that
whatever europeans may admit in britain
it's responsible for one percent of
carbon emissions so sure we might hit
net zero but that i don't i put to you
would that even move the dial on the
global warring problem if we did that
and if it wouldn't then we are looking
at india and china now and and china
gets the majority of its energy now from
coal burning fuel plants and as a
country it's still got gdp per capita
like a quarter of that of britain
they've got a lot of poverty to
eliminate india's got 115 million people
in extreme poverty so they are not
really going to go at a particularly
fast pace because they need to get their
people out of the hunger line now once
they do that
they might get into lifestyle so the
interesting thing about uh climate
policy is it intersects with all sorts
of other policies as well um one of the
other main issues that
that is plaguing both china and india
is the problem of air pollution air
pollution mainly from the burning of
fossil fuels is causing hundreds of
thousands of premature deaths in these
countries
they have an absolute urgent need
to move away from polluting
energy sources
and they are doing so um one of the
things uh that they're doing um in in
india uh you know they have open
auctions for
new power supplies those auctions are
being won by solar
uh um plans not by new coal plants this
this notion that uh that that coal is
cheap uh
and therefore everyone is using it it's
not cheap because they're having to pay
the costs of the associated air
pollution uh the uh the the the deaths
from uh from coal mining uh the
appalling conditions of the miners uh
fossil fuels are not uh
this this wonderful panacea that is
going to bring everybody out of poverty
because if it were uh they would have
done it a hundred years ago why did that
because of technology
china's made incredible progress out of
poverty over the last 20 years has gone
from 60 to 1 in absolute poverty and if
you look at india's causes of deaths
right now the fossil fuels are nowhere
near it you've got something like a
million children in your diarrhea every
year you have something like three
million cases of um tuberculosis these
are things that are linked to india's
poverty and when countries rise to their
agrarian knees they do so by living a
bit more like we do in the west and that
means fossil fuel
right so but
but the developing countries are not
just adopting what we did with the same
history they are able to leapfrog a lot
of the things that we did like there is
there is never going to be a
comprehensive landline telephone
industry in india or china because they
leaped ahead of that and now they have
cell phones we can help them and they
will help us uh by helping uh to both
develop and
uh and uh and manufacture uh the
technology that will allow them to
get ahead of the problems that we've had
associated with fossil fuels um
this is not this is not a uh this is not
an easy task um and it's clear that uh
energy needs in in india and other
developing nations uh are are very are
very real um but we can be helping them
and they can help us by doing uh the
most of that with renewables right now
but benefit we've had china promised to
hit net zero by 2060. that's a pretty
big promise we've had india promise to
do it by 2070 again that's not to be
sneezed at so i put to you that the cop
26 is actually producing some tangible
program process and it's doing on a time
scale we're sure we measure in decades
but we measure our own pressure admit
progress in decades what matters surely
is that the world's countries are now
beginning to get agree to the
decarbonisation agenda which um gavin
schmidt has just set out
fraser look let's be real here
um china and india are making these kind
of conditional pledges you know these
pledges are conditional on trillions of
dollars
having to be
transferred from
the us and europe to the developing
world it's conditional these are not
kind of pledges we're doing this no they
are only doing this if the money flows
in their direction and can i just say
let's forget for a moment india and
china and asia and africa and the rest
of the developing world let's forget all
of this and look at the us
president biden came to cop and made
some pledges no one believes a word he
makes he says no one believes that he's
trustworthy or credible he can't even
get his pledge through his own party
never mind through the senate
the us is never going to give up on its
huge treasure of fossil fuels believe
you me there's no chance
that the us will give up on oil gas and
coal for the next 30 years
simple
what i'm hearing from you benny is just
excuses uh for why nobody should do
anything you already know
that's not the way that's not the truth
what i'm saying is
the problem the west and the greens and
the climate activists
have is they've
basically made a huge mistake by
believing that you can solve the problem
of co2 emissions with renewables the
problem is that the world is looking at
the countries with high level of
renewables and they are seeing all sorts
of problems whether it's rising energy
prices whether it's instable national
grids whether it's blackouts if
if and that's a big if
these kind of claims with you know it's
one minute before doomsday we're facing
extinction and so if that were true
governments would take policies where
you can actually produce energy reliably
and cost effectively and take the public
with you give up renewables go for
nuclear go for low carbon natural gas
and then you can decarbonize you cannot
decarbonize the economy with renewables
that is what the world is realizing
today gavin schmitz and benny pfizer
thanks very much indeed finally clara
you might have heard of it it's a new
buy now pay later card responsible for
pretty much a quarter of card
transactions in sweden is now coming to
britain but is this a new loan shark
trying to lure people into debt which
they don't will not be able to afford to
pay off that's what stella creasy
suspects she's labor mp for wilton still
and she was instrumental in campaigning
against wonga the payday loan company
and stella are you sure you've got the
right targets this time because karna is
far far different to what wonga and the
other payday loan companies used to be
oh yes
if it walks like a duck and it talks
like a duck it's a duck one of the
pernicious things about buying a buy now
pay later credit is that they're trying
to tell people that because they don't
charge interest there aren't the same
problems with them but actually these
companies market themselves to retailers
so the retailers pay the fees and they
market themselves on the basis that you
will end up spending 30 to 40 more than
you would have done if you use your
debit card or indeed a credit card to
pay for things because the payments are
spaced out
fundamentally if you can't afford
something at full price spreading out
the cost for most people especially with
the cost of living crisis is going to
end in tears and the similarities with
the payday lending industry are that
they are trying to get people hooked on
their form of credit as as you talk
about with sweden well last christmas
one in four pounds in this country was
spent using a buy now pay later
company they get people hooked on this
way of managing their money so that
they're spending more than they can
afford and it's ending in tears what's
different is at least with a payday loan
you could go to the financial services
ombudsman if you thought you'd been
mis-sold credit because these companies
currently aren't regulated in the uk you
can't go to the ombudsman if you get
into difficulty with them so there's no
protection for consumers at all right
but you talk about it as if they're um
companies preying on victims i mean the
article in this week's magazine was
written by my colleague gus carter he
thinks that they're great he says that
he was quite like help managing his
payments and he doesn't like credit
cards his mom and dad taught him he says
to stay away from visa and mastercard
he's doing that but in clarinet he gets
a chance to spread payments over a
number of times he doesn't have the
great am i going to run out of beer
money his example before the um before
payday and so isn't it simply the case
that younger generation is seeing a
different way of financing things and
prefers
clarinet's style of regular payments to
having to worry if there's money in your
bank or not and if you if you can't
repair the puncture in your in your
bicycle attire and when you and rather
than negotiate alone with wonga what one
girl was something like 6 000
of course it was there exploiting people
who couldn't afford to spend that six
thousand percent
but clark is 20
so isn't this a generational thing
aren't people like you and me
simply too old to see that young people
do want to use clarinet and i think the
under 30s that is their demographic
oh fraser i completely agree with you
that you and i are way past it when it
comes to modern technology but there's a
very simple premise here which is if
people don't have the money to be able
to pay off the bill they don't have the
money to be able to pay off the bill and
what we're seeing is a large volume of
young people getting into financial
difficulty with these companies because
they aren't able to spread the payments
they aren't able to budget in the way
that your colleague gus is talking about
that's why the financial conduct
authority raised concerns about the
affordability assessments that these
companies were doing just as they did
with payday loans eventually that these
companies are lending people money that
they don't have to begin with so it
doesn't matter whether you spread the
payment if you can't make the payment
that's the challenge that we face here
the additional problem is that there is
no protection from being missiled in
that way and what we're seeing is an
industry that's evolving very quickly
you're absolutely right when it first
started and i would say as i've always
said with payday lending there's a space
for all these forms of credit if they're
properly regulated and consumers are
given fair information about them but
this industry is evolving incredibly
quickly so in the last couple of weeks
alone we've seen these companies being
offered on betting sites and people
using them to buy basics and food and
we're also seeing banks now offering buy
now pay later services and making an
assessment as to whether you can afford
to use that service which sounds like a
massive conflict of interest because as
you say the penalty when you can't repay
is a debt and it's a debt with interest
right but mclaren has been going for 15
years now i mean i i'm married to a
suite i've got lots of friends and
family in sweden and i'll give you two
examples that really changed my mind
about clarinet because like you i was
quite suspicious about it when it came
along but here's the example one is my
sister-in-law she loves buying clothes
with clarinet they send her a whole
bunch of things she basically what
doesn't fit her she sends back she only
ends up paying for what she actually
keeps so that's quite effective
previously you have to buy all of this
stuff and get a refund if it doesn't fit
you with clarinet you can buy it and
send it back if it doesn't fit you're
never actually charged for it that's
helpful i've also got another friend who
runs a vitamin selling company in sweden
now he would say i'm saying that his
checkout if you've got one click with
klarner that helps him
sell so much for a small company but
having to do it himself the payment
technology is incredibly simple
consumers like it the reason they spend
more is because they have to worry about
what their credit card number is they
can do it on a click now you're saying
what if they get all in terrible debt
well i put it to you if that was
happening we'd see that in sweden
already where clarinet has taken the
market by storm and said the average
balance of a clarinet account is
something like 45 pounds in credit
because people don't really use it to
get into debt compare that to visa and
mastercard where the average balance is
a heavy negative so surely if what you
were saying is true we would have seen
it by now in the many countries where
clarinet has been active for quite some
time
well don't take my word for it fraser
take the word of the citizens advice
bureau and which and step change the
debt advice charities who are all seeing
people getting into financial difficulty
with buy now pay later companies what
your sister laura describes is not to do
with buy now pay later there are plenty
of ways in which you can buy and send
things back that's not specific to that
particular industry but you don't have
to pay for it until you because if
that's a difference
well you do pay for it
you just don't pay as much for it and if
you are buying more than you can
actually afford to because it's not
clear to you what the price is and your
second example is one of the worries
that we have is that often
um by now pay later it's a default
option on many websites now because the
retailers need to recoup the money
they've spent on the service it means
that many people don't realize they've
got into a buy now pay later
um
agreement
i am not here as i never i never tried
to get rid of payday lending i wanted it
regulated properly i wanted to cap on
the cost of credit i still want to cap
on all forms of credit with the buy now
pay later industry i want them to behave
as a credit company because they are a
credit company and that means following
the regulations that we have in this
country about affordability criteria
about fair payments to consumers and
about the processes when things go wrong
so that if consumers do get into
difficulty they can go to the financial
services ombudsman and the financial
conduct authority research is pretty
compelling as to why that's an important
thing to do the challenge for all of us
is that that came out in january this
year and the government finally agreed
to our call to regulate these companies
but we're not going to see that
regulation until next year which means
we've got another christmas and indeed
black friday where these companies will
be unregulated and as i've said they're
evolving incredibly quickly so it's not
a question of whether these companies
should exist or not it's whether they
should play by the rules that every
other credit card company and every
other credit agency in this country does
have to play by and at the moment they
don't and they're exploiting that and
our constituents are missing out
accordingly
right i imagine quite a few of your
constituents we're buying stuff on
clarinet this christmas if you look at
the way it's markets evolving in britain
it's quite a lot it's not just chlorina
by the way they're several of these buy
now pay later companies have to pay and
other similar ones and i've met with all
of them i promise you for them right i
guess you could clearly get the bad rep
because it's the biggest is the biggest
obvious or a good rep depending how you
see it and
was also encouraging people during the
pandemic and that's why i got their
adverts taken down along with the
brilliant alice tapper who is a
financial journalist who's been
investigating them they were encouraging
people to spend money to lift their mood
you should never get into debt because
you've got mental health challenges and
that's where the advertising conduct
authority rightly intervened to
challenge them about the language they
were using and the way in which they're
promoting their service so
all of these companies have challenges
they've all now recognized and welcomed
the need for regulation the question for
all of us is how quickly that regulation
can come in and how we make sure it's
fair to all forms of credit
right so you're saying that as long as
it's as long as it's regulated and right
now it doesn't because it's new and
nobody knew it quite knows what to make
of it then you quite be happy with the
britain where clarinet was as big as it
is in sweden right now
i want my my constituents to have a
level playing field when it comes to
their credit options i want them to have
proper protections and be able to borrow
in a way that is transparent and fair
i'm not here wearing a hair suit
for fraser the point for me is right now
this industry isn't regulated it's very
evidently exploiting those loopholes as
a result and consumers are getting into
financial difficulty the evidence that
that is happening is piling up in this
country partly i think because we have a
different attitude towards death in this
country perhaps to some other european
nations also because of the cost of
living crisis that we follow frankly if
people have too much month at the end of
their money it doesn't matter whether
they're using a payday loan or a buy now
pay later agreement or indeed a credit
card they've got an issue to deal with
the challenge is right now the best
protection you have is to take out a
payday loan because at least that cost
is capped we have a long way to go in
this country making sure that consumers
can borrow in a way that is transparent
and fair and that's good for our economy
because it's not good for our economy to
build up massive amounts of personal
debt that people can't sustain
stella creasy labour mp for wolfenstein
scourge of the payday lenders thanks
very much for joining us on spectator tv
now that's it for this week and we hope
you've enjoyed this episode if you have
you might want to consider subscribing
to this show which you can do for free
by clicking on the subscribe button
underneath the screen if you click the
wii bell as well that means you get
notified every time a new episode of
spectator tv comes along
thank you for watching and thanks to
cindy you and max jeffrey our producers
[Music]
you